all right mmm
man sometimes you know the thing about
life for me mmm call him supposed to
clap three times before I start
recording because so will [ __ ] let me do
it again that second clap was kind of
weak could you hear it you know that was
a weak damn boy
I got weak claps hold on there we go
three mighty claps and you're supposed
to do that so the audio engineer my
producer Nick so he can line up the
video and the audio together and able to
sync this and put this out into the into
the world so just so you know sometime
if you ever hear people clapping or
making a loud sound in the beginning you
know these the sticks sometimes on
acting set they'll be like alright take
two and they do that that's so they can
line the audio up with the video I don't
know if that makes any sense I don't
know if you care I don't know if I care
I honestly do not know if I even care
but thank you guys for being here let's
let's get into it
[Music]
[Applause]
get that I hit up gang gang that was
submitted by rusty Scott and that's some
new music right there that was submitted
by rusty Scott and thank you brother for
sending that hand a wild
I was listening through some stuff
thinking like well what would be good to
kind of what would sound fun to start to
show off what else he sent this one into
I'll play this one as well here we go
[Music]
those crazy as hell
here's some stories about this pass
[Music]
man that's crazy right there and so
that's a real song that came in and
Thank You rusty Scott for sending those
in that second one man that's the one I
was looking for accident played a
different first but I'm glad you guys
got to hear both of them that second one
made me laugh man that one made me put
me in a good spirit right here out the
gate out the gate hope your weekend was
good and now we back in life you know
it's back in lifetime that's the thing
sometimes man life comes at you fast boy
do what what did they put into life to
make it so fast you know that I'm right
I remember being young and life was so
slow do you could take a two-hour nap
and wake up and it would be earlier than
when you went to sleep
may you had forever remember when you
were young and you had forever
there was no it just you had forever man
I missed that
I missed that you could yeah it just I
don't I guess that was it when you're
young you know everything is so new
everything is so novel you know that's
one thing I miss as well like not only
give so much time but everything you did
had such it was so it had such a
magnitude to it it had such a Mac like
if you fell in love with somebody that
[ __ ] was deep
you know you woke up in the middle of
the night you had love just just hanging
off of your bones you know you had just
you had I mean you felt your heart felt
like it was just just thinking about
that person constantly you know when you
had that love when you know when you had
that young love inside of you it would
just you know we just I mean it you
could feel it just hanging off your your
neck just with its arms wrapped around
your neck like a hungry baby
that young love man it was just
everything was when you were young
everything had such magnitude everything
had such girth and such claws
everything was so real and heavy and
strong and light and heavy and light at
the same time it was heavy because it
was new and novel and it was light
because you had you had time to explore
it in time too for it to work out her to
not work out man I missed that about
being young I just missed that you know
like if you remember going out on the
town when you were young
you're sixteen years old or you were you
know twenty-two and you hit the town
anything could [ __ ] happen brah a
friend pulled up he showed up in a
[ __ ] van he didn't even Drive a van
one of his parents drove a van and one
of his parents who were probably were
not super smart let their son a 16 year
old kid take the [ __ ] van to go out
at night is there any how has that not
caught on to parents don't let your
[ __ ] son take the van a van is just a
trap house on wheels anything could
happen to it if somebody had a car it
was like ah things was limited you know
you could ride around you could listen
to some music you could put some beers
in a trunk you could smoke a joint right
somebody had a [ __ ] van dude if your
friend had a van bruh anything could
happen
you could start a small business you
could run a butcher shop in the back of
that [ __ ] son you know what I'm saying
y'all doing 40 miles an hour and [ __ ]
dropping bacon bits out the back in a
van anything could happen in a van
you could start a little family back
there you could run it you could start
an advertising agency back there you
know it's Mad Men back here in the in
the third row dude if you ever had a van
with that
third row anything could happen in a van
but I remember you were young the night
the night was thick well you got out of
it you know your friend picked you up at
eight o'clock y'all rolled out if he was
girls he was a couple of bad [ __ ]
rollin out you know put in your [ __ ] you
know put in a real you know put your
strongest tampon in and hit the town we
doing it tonight
Danijela you know you know what I'm
saying
Maria you know what I'm saying huh huh
Susan huh Tiffany
tonight we letting it all hang out no
bra tonight girl I'm letting these
titties touch the wind man I miss that
being young you every dude I remember we
go out man I remember one time my buddy
picked me up and he had a van he had the
longest van you could get if you ever
seen that van it was like for church
right but then every now and then
somebody who wasn't with the church
would get the church van dude that thing
had nine rows I'm saying the eighth row
was just force in the ninth row brother
had usually like a little you know
cooler back there a couple that gets you
a couple of uh you know some juice
hitters some you know Capri Suns you
know you get them Capri Suns and you're
just juicing yourself up just dousing
yourself up with fruit juices in that
ninth row then you jump back over the
seat under that eighth row and sin again
boy you know I'm saying drop your sins
stick in and you had maybe a lady back
there if he was being real wild you
might have had a little man back there
with you you know and that was it man
that somebody somebody who wasn't with
the church got that church van and
anything could happen dude they have the
fourth row that would that was for
remedial reading they had tutoring going
on in the fourth row the fifth row they
had somebody with usually grilling
cheeses or you know doing grilling
cheese is there somebody hit you with
that small that just that if if I don't
know if you ever eaten a grill and
cheese but they're good you know
somebody something was how to
dog back there and they were talking
about you know maybe they were gonna
listen to widespread panic or something
I mean anything that lost him when
somebody got that when somebody that
wasn't with the church got the church
van mm man dirty magic could happen you
know I'm saying
dirty [ __ ] magic you know they had
dirt you know the one of the roads there
was somebody doing magic or pretending
they were doing magic but really they
were just trying to touch each you know
just trying to get a little bit of touch
you know a little bit of David David
copping feels you know what I'm singing
oh come back here I'm gonna pull a
rabbit out this hat but then you get
back there and the only thing in that
hat is you know a little bit of regular
[ __ ] I mean like oh this this ain't a
rabbit this ain't a rabbit you know but
I'm gonna let that thing hop around on
me man being young man when you worry
man anything could happen when you were
young and when you had a friend that got
to somebody that wasn't with the church
got that Church for him could you
believe a parent much less a parent with
the church first of all what is the
church doin cell in that van back out
into the world what do they think is
gonna happen not every family has 19
children remember that vein of the long
van I'm talking about that thing was
like a 40 cedar you could put two
baseball teams in the van and still have
a couple rows for referees to sit
between them but any man with some wild
stuff having with somebody who wasn't
with the church got ahold of that church
van and they had a boy like that in my
town this beautiful boy named Samson and
he would come pick us up in that church
van bro do one of the windows
immediately we couldn't get it open
somebody just [ __ ] broke that [ __ ]
out with a hammer
and we were so full we were in like the
sixth row you couldn't even hear the
glass break in the front and we were
smoking Giants in there we was smoking
just American children's Giants just
blowing just huffing
huge amounts of marijuana into our lungs
and I'm talking them horse leg hitters
man we had one boy with us he was so
weak he couldn't even hold up some of
the big Giants we was smoking
he couldn't even hold them he had to
hold him with both arms and then also
get one of his legs up there to hold
that giant you know you had to [ __ ]
put up he had a he had to get two hands
and a foot up there to hold that jaunt
up to his mouth and he was just huh do
people smoking horse legs dude
equestrians you know I'm saying the kind
of joints that might test positive for
raw for doping for steroids
give them be horse legs baby yeah dude I
remember I got high one time you know
they'd pick me up at 8 o'clock I got so
high fell asleep at 8:15 I was
unconscious right but still I was young
man and you could fall you could faint
or pass how you could die when you were
young and you wake back up two hours
later and people were like where you
been you're like I've been [ __ ] dead
in row six and like we'll come on back
man you're like I'm back now you know
this is reincarnation past that jaunt
again and you get John it up but I
remember all kind of stuff people you
know using some you know making uh you'd
have a 1 row 7 or row 8 somebody making
illegal Footwear anything could happen
you know they had a couple of children
back there with print and presses you
know you know making propaganda Flyers
anything could happen you know the first
or second row that's where people that
really you know some people were just
looking for a ride hitchhikers everybody
was in that in that that church van when
somebody with hood that wasn't what the
church got a hold of it you know you'd
have people in in the second row you'd
have air or the third row you'd have
people touching each other's crotches
you know fungal bogging you know fungal
bong in each other or but by the seventh
row that if they'd be raising a child
the same people later that evening it
was just you know anything could happen
you get married in row five
you know what I'm saying child-rearing
in row seven divorced in row eleven
working for the city in row twelve BAM
son you got a whole [ __ ] life going
on in that church van boy thing had 46
rows dude they had a funeral going on
row 39 somebody gone somebody died and
this time died for full time this full
time 40 hours a week dead we're not
talking part time but man that was a
wild that was a wild and that was wild
being young and I just remember that I
remember that being young when and you
know one thing people don't realize this
about being young or maybe people do and
maybe I just just learned it and so
suddenly I think that people don't
realize it in that crazy house sometimes
you'll be like you'll just learn
something you'll be like well what
people don't understand people do
understand it you're just an idiot
brother and by you I'm talking to myself
but what but but one thing that I didn't
realize until recently was you know the
reason why time is so it feels so big
when you're young white why it feels
like if so much time is because time is
new to you think about it say if you are
10 years old and you have summer break
right that's say you have three months
and you only been alive for 10 years so
three months it's like two percent of
your life it's like a it's like it's
like a percent of your life you know
that that 3 months if you've only been a
lot for 10 years is like a whole 1
percent of your life or two I don't know
what but it's a big part of your life
you've only been a lot for 10 years so 3
months of that a summer break that's
huge
but now three months now I'm in my 30s
baby 3 months that's nothing that's like
a you know that's like a 1/10 of a
percent you know it's and so he goes by
faster because I've gotten used to that
but it's not as big of a chunk of my
life anymore three months is a little
bitty bit of my life now because I've
been alive so much longer
and so of course three months goes by
fast because it's in the big scope of my
life it's not as it's a little bit or at
least that's why I feels the allocate
goes by fast as well because it doesn't
hold the same magnitude now three months
back when you're ten years old three
months it is a lifetime and it goes slow
and there's more intricacies up to it
and there's more moments and there's
more you know there's more magnitude
because it's a huge part of your life
three months now man
dude I'll go into a coma for nine months
and feel like I probably didn't miss
[ __ ] because it's that that amount of
time in a bigger life span isn't very
much it doesn't hold as much weight the
time I'm living on now is more
lightweight you know I'm really I guess
I romanticize a lot about being young
it's wow because at the same time while
I you know like I think it you know an
emotional about I didn't really enjoy a
lot of being young men are still those
things when you were young it was just
man I remember I remember being young
dude I'll tell this story this is a
little kind of out there I got I got I
remember going over to my um my buddies
and he had his mutt you know uh you know
my buddy's mother was you know you know
I had some friends I had some attractive
mothers and so I go over there dude I
remember sometimes like just taken I
mean this is out there man what are we
even talking about but I remember taking
my buddy's mother's brassiere and I mean
just getting those and at first I would
just do one one breast you know as a
child I remember being young and this is
when I was going through poverty you
know and I was just permed up boy if you
even touched me on the back I would
probably just just come somewhere you
know like if you even patted me on the
back or even just you know I remember
one time like I'm like I'm like a like a
mosquito or a butterfly just landed on
my cheek and just that touch just made
me just spray out
you know that's just kind of how it was
I could fall down and you know if I
scraped both my knees at the same time
it would just I would just see Jackie
lat and that's just kind of you know
just when you're at that young age and
then she's that / but he's just flying
through your body
you dosed your blood is even blood most
of us just you know like semen but kind
of tinted red you know cuz you just had
that young age but I remember going over
to my buddy's house about this stuff
whatever whatever what are what are
these stories inside of us if we'll
bring them out what are they what are
they if we don't let things out of
ourselves but I remember going to my
buddy's house and his mother had them
had them brassieres you know she used to
have them beautiful Brasi airs and I
would take them dude I would sneak off
in a tear um they had a hamper you know
and we didn't have a hamper at miles
hampers rich people had hampers did we
had we didn't have a special think about
a hamper dude a hamper is a special cage
for your dirty clothes like they've been
so bad they gotta be locked up we didn't
have dad do my dirty clothes lived on
the floor you know I'm saying we was you
know I'm saying I even remember if you
didn't have a pillow at night you just
put all your dirty clothes on one stack
you know make sure the socks and the
unders we're down at the bottom of the
stack and this that's your pillow right
there you know I'm saying sleeping all
your it just you know sleeping all your
dirt you ality but yeah man rich people
had a hamper if you had it people out of
hand price I what you take off your
dirties and you put them in that special
tall box that's crazy
I remember thinking they've them those
people were living high on the hog when
they had that but so I go over to my
buddy's house and they had that hamper
and I knew his mama had it some
brassieres in there and boy I [ __ ] go
into the restaurant like I gotta go pee
you know and dude I be peeing for 40
minutes you know they they I mean they
must have thought I had a damn you know
I had to hook up with the Colorado River
or something you know where I was
working freelance for the Monongahela
because I would just be an
wasn't really peeing I was just
pretending I was peeing I would first I
would actually pee I mean I would save
up as much pee as I had I wouldn't pee
for two or three days because I knew I
was gonna go in that bathroom and after
pretend like I was peeing and while I
was pretending I'd get that Brasi air
and I put that thumb right up on my nose
and take that hit man in that first hit
that first smell it was a little bit of
had a little bit of motherhood in it you
know cuz this was my buddy's mother but
and now but that was just a half a
nostril of motherhood and the rest of
that was all just sensuality
you know because I cooked one of my
buddies you know I told you had a hot
mother and his mother had that hot and a
student she had like sometimes you would
see her shoulders and I was just good
god I remember seeing her shoulders and
I couldn't even see for like a couple
days brow just people you know my eyes
would just fill up on the inside with
just semen and just you know young comb
you know that just that young fervor and
that's just sex just running rampant
through your body then when you're a boy
a lot of women don't understand this and
girls honor and maybe it's like that for
girls at certain points in your life but
when you're a young boy you're basically
you were just a you're like just you're
just whole you're basically an uber for
hormones that's all you are you're not
even an uber uber is kind of classy
you're a lift you are a straight up
lifts for hormones you're not working
for yourself anymore
your body has overcome your brain is
overcome by simin you know and by the
dark arts and by the desires
you know Pandora's Box just cracked open
somewhere back in your you know your
module er your hypothalamus or something
the things just leaking just you know
just that fiery flames of just wanting
to spray out so anyway I'd be there in
the bathroom and I went in that wouldn't
have peed for a couple days because I
had to kill time and network you can't
do something you'll smell a bra and I'm
have you ever seen um cider house rules
but sometimes the man inside our house
rules the you know the
you know good night my kings of New
England or mine or whatever the daddy
the main man inside our house rules for
those who hit that ether and he'll wake
up an hour later and that's what it was
like when you got that hit of that Brasi
air bruh oh man your whole body would
just be just like rich it would just be
erect just with just that sensual just
just like rigor mortis but like ditka
mortis you know just your whole body
would just turn into almost like a penis
and sometimes my eyes I just fade out
I'd be unconscious just so high on just
[ __ ] being hopped up on sensuality
and pervert he just flying through my
[ __ ] veins bruh you know and you
didn't know if you're gonna black out
you don't know what the [ __ ] was gonna
happen so you'd have to pee you know
that's why you had to save up as much
urine I remember I would get like 3 or 4
cups of water put those on the sink
before I was gonna pee then I would
start peeing right pee as slow as I
could and I could pee dude I was like I
was the Greg Louganis of pissed and you
know I'm saying
I was Greg Louganis do you know I'm
saying I was the mark spitz a piss bro I
was at Carl Lewis you know I'm saying I
was at Carl Lewis of the urethra or
ureter or whatever it's called and I
would just you I would pee I could pee
for four minutes
I could be for four I mean the softest
dream you've ever even seen you know I'm
saying like you could you could see the
beginning of the pee coming out of me
you could look the other way you could
look at like a picture on the wall and
then look really back quickly and the
pee wouldn't have hit the water yet
that's how soft like a urinate
I mean I was just so so so soft almost
like I was just pissing down II just
pissing that snuggle softener brother
that [ __ ] might not even ever hit the
toilet you knock a piss real real soft
so I could pee for about four minutes
then and I was still just taking huffs
off that bra you know you're
just peeing and huff and dude and at
first I would just do one breast you
know one cup and that thing might have
been a dam I remember I think it was a
seed but God if it was a d.o then wonder
I ended up in the dark hearts cuz Satan
had me early Satan had me early just
riding that titty facemask you know and
I would just be and you know if you
inhales if you inhale so many times at
once you pass out no I'm saying the Lord
get make sure lungs it's that's a
two-way your lungs are a two-way street
you can't just keep riding them in words
and then your brains gonna be like nah
man we shutting you down for a minute
because you don't know how to work your
own lungs you [ __ ] pervert and that's
what happened to me I was just lung up
on that that titty holster and I would
just faint but if I didn't faint I
wanted to get as many Huff's as I could
off of it and so I what I would do then
is if I ran out of urine I'd start
slowly pouring the P the the cups of
water into the toilet so then they still
think I'm peeing so now in my mind it
doesn't regulate oh they don't think
that somebody can't pee for nine minutes
you know they don't think that none of
that regulated I just thought oh of
course they know when daddy's in here
and and tallit that I go hard I go hard
down here in the pee paint you know what
I'm saying I ain't no wimp you know I'm
saying I'm that uh that I came I'm the
hakeem olajuwon of urination I'd be down
here you know I'm that Dikembe pissed
Tumbo no no no no you know I'm saying IP
down here IP and that's what happened
man and I would pee and just Huff that
brassiere and then it way got to the
point where I was huffing both cups at
the same time and that's when you know
that's when you know you're starting to
set yourself up for failure but it's
quit it's amazing how things will
progress anything will progress if you
let it do - first you the door first
you're just looking at one piece of dark
art and next thing you know you're in a
museum and it's all dark arts
all it is man it's just Picasso's just
piss Carson and vagina van guns you feel
me
it's all the dark arts then but it's
amazing how if you let it you'll if you
keep bro if you keep flirting with
disaster disaster is gonna take you on a
date and then disaster is gonna take you
on a second date and then disaster is
gonna [ __ ] you so I'm saying it just it
builds anything you do builds and but
yeah next thing I was always - lawful
one seat cup just and I was just trying
to get even a wit cuz my brain would
manifest that there was a smell of tit
in there that there was a straight-up
you know that SOT that sup that smell of
tit and I would just Huff that brassiere
and she had this thick brassieres -
nothing lacy I couldn't hint dude if it
had been something lacy like doily like
that breast doily right out of my entire
heart would have busted open and just
come Fetty would have just flown all
over the universe and unicorns would
have danced in circles and the devil
would have [ __ ] you know the devil
would have flared up and known he had
won around but I couldn't I didn't do
that you know she had those thicker kind
of you know my buddies mother had this
thicker kind of bra cierres and I would
just Huff them things and just feel just
feel just lit up but they're the the
tough part was that's how I started you
know I didn't it I didn't find
comfortable ways to interact with women
you know and so that was some of the
tough part of it but man being young and
just everything was so heavy when you
were young it was heavy because it was
new and it was it was light because you
had time to explore it and you knew that
it wasn't so severe in the cinah in the
timeline of things it wasn't severe but
in the novelty of things it was so
severe and it was so intense oh that's
one thing I miss about being young it
was
[Music]
it was
it was this the discovery you know
everything you were Christopher Columbus
our Christina Columbus everything you
did everything you did was you landed on
something new
hmm I was wild it was fun as exciting I
want to thank you guys for the call when
so many calls came in from last week
you know the episode put out and I want
to let you know also that this week's
episode is brought to you about great
block pizza a lot of people don't know
that or don't realize that and that's
okay but great block pizzas at 1811 Pico
Boulevard in Los Angeles and you can get
that hitter and they got beautiful
choices over there calzones and in
pieces and all kind of stuff and they're
good people over there stopping there
tell them you know me and get that
hitter also I want to let you know that
today's episode is brought to you by
lakeside maple and lakeside maple I'm
gonna be straight up with you they got
some oh man if you'd like to have a
snack and I noticed this I have a snack
while I Drive around you know and I like
to have a little bit of snack over and a
side seat because if I don't have a
companion with me and I like to have a
snack over there something I can touch
you know and it could be either touching
a friend or just touching a snack and
that snack for me right now as a
lakeside maple they got trail mix and
it's made with pure maple syrup some
people dripping that you know running on
fake EMS and all types of fake EMS out
there not them they're running on pure
maple syrup it's crafted in small
batches it's all natural they're a small
business they have original spicy okay
which was a strippers name I used to
know over there in Toledo when I used to
go see all of that and ginger chai which
also I think is like honestly it could
be an Asian name but all our mixes all
of their mixes are made by hand and
they're gluten-free and vegan free if
you're into that now if you like gluten
and you like vegan you can also have
this because I like those things and I
have it and I love it but you're gonna
love it man lakeside maple get that mix
you know I'm saying sometimes you don't
have enough mix in your life will they
put a mix in a bag for you lakeside
maple dot-com code Theo th EO at
checkout for 15% off go on get that
hitter what else man oh I got some dates
coming up I'm gonna rattle them off to
you really quick you know I'll be in a
Skyway theater Minneapolis Minnesota
that's next weekend Oh
his fourth has sold out Chicago is
almost sold out August 16th through the
18th Laugh Factory
Zane he's in Nashville September 14th
and 15th and then we got Toronto just
for laughs September 20th through the
24th you know and uh you know it's crazy
because some of these clubs they don't
pay you fair man you know it's so crazy
being an artist man is scary these
people don't pay you fair and you know
it's a lot of this just this [ __ ]
business man you know but then also I
just need to recognize that it's a times
you know it's a tough part for me is
being great being grateful but not
getting you're not getting [ __ ] you
know and I think that's probably a lot
of people you know that's where a lot of
us live you know cuz it's tough because
there's moments where you know you're
getting screwed right and then it's like
how do you handle that you know and it's
just messed up a lot of these places
they're not doing anything for Yusef you
know ya they letting you come there but
I'd rather go do the shows then at a
place that it's gonna appreciate us you
know that's gonna you know split the
money up more fairly or give away some
dough to make the tickets cheaper donate
some of the cash you know some of these
places man so I'm just trying to work
you know I'm trying to work with good
places I'm trying to make these people
give me fair deals and if they're not
then I'm not going there you know I'm
not going there because it's not fair
you know being greedy isn't [ __ ] cool
I don't think it's cool and we try to
work with businesses and stuff that are
doing cool that are you know we try to
be fair with our businesses in the ads
I'm not gonna try to sell you guys
[ __ ] on here just have ads if I can
help it you know I mean selling know
Casper mattresses bro soft ass mattress
dude my back I can't even feel my
[ __ ] spine anymore come on and I know
I'm getting angry here but some of the
others don't like the unfairness of
things I don't like it you don't have to
be unfair you know you don't have to be
unfair so but then also it's like I know
I have to pay my dues you know so it's
tough I guess that's where my tough
thing comes in and not getting that you
know and recognizing it's hard to
recognize sometimes if you know you're
being mistreated or if you're just
paying your
doos so but I think some of that goes
back to trusting our instincts and if
we're not sure we can always just be
honest with somebody and say hey look I
don't think feel like you're treating me
fairly and and what do you think about
that and then at least at least then I
guess I'm not sitting there wondering
but anyway maddening meaning getting all
that stuff some of that's my own stuff
but we had a you know a lot of people
called in last week about last week's
episode so I want to I want to get to a
few of those calls here we go thanks for
calling Ronnie Ronnie from Philly dude I
feel like half of Philly is named Ronnie
men and women you know I'm saying it's
my brother Ronnie and this my little
sister also Ronnie they are let's hear
more thank you for calling Ronnie City
of Brotherly Love - and a lot of
brothers up in Philly - man you know I'm
saying if you don't have a black friend
go to Philly
you can't even leave without one they
should have a gift shop in Philly meet a
black friend
oh we're listen man I was listening to
the stairs weekend's episode seem like
you're beating yourself up there a
little bit you know I realize you're uh
you know pretty stressed out on the run
and all that and you know I'm just
calling I'm gonna let you know man you
always have our backs but I'll call it
but you know that we got your back to
the warm you know all the current codes
are you taking all the countless people
that you've held man I mean and I you
know I haven't even call it in myself
and you've helped me immensely I can't
even you know putting the words I'm
listening to your podcast you know we
did four weeks help ourselves
yeah with my thanks for calling Ronnie I
appreciate that I'm not cutting you off
I just wanted to just take a moment and
say thank you let's hear more our own
dark guard you know what I mean you know
I got I got problems you know twisting
off to three times a night myself
man saw who and that's heavy work that's
heavy work two or three times a night
that's heavy work man that's heavy
lifting you know and it's crazy cuz that
third time is that way is it joy in that
what is that the second time it's a
little bit of you know painful joy kind
of you know it feels good but it also
hurts kind of kind of like we're in
tight leather
but the third time you you know you
tempting that little baby [ __ ] nut
dragon that's living on top of your nuts
that thing that's a tough when that
third rip bra hmm but thank you for
calling Ronnie let's hear a little more
it's best yeah here and you know I
recently uh you know I stopped drinking
I'm on sober and you know a lot of that
has to do with with your health man and
I'm not calling about me though I'm just
calling to let you know that we're here
to support you and you know you always
have our backs but uh you know listeners
I got your back too man your uh your
beautiful scroller man and you gotta
treat yourself good cuz I know you
deserve it feel thanks bro I appreciate
that man it's nice to me just say uh
yeah I appreciate it man
you know thanks you know thank you you
know thank you for yeah for the call man
you know it's weird I don't you know I
don't feel like I'll do anything
different or anything wild or you know
extracurricular I mean I just feel like
that's part of you know and I'm not
discrediting what you're saying man it's
very sweet of you to say that but I feel
like that's what our group is and
there's a part in your call right there
when you said you know when you started
were kind of sharing about yourself a
little bit you say you know but this
isn't about me I want to let you know
this about you and that kind of touched
me a little bit man because um you know
because I think in in today's world
that's we all need some of that you know
we only need to know for a second it's
so crazy
we're also like me me me it's like such
a me world right now that when somebody
says hey this isn't about me this is
about you man it makes you if it makes
you feel something you know it makes you
feel something uh but I you know I
appreciate that that you guys had my
back and I felt I felt that man I got so
many nice message from people dude I got
so many some of them were so funny but I
couldn't figure a way how to like
reincorporate them back out into the
world there's some calls in here some
were
you know on Instagram and just messages
I got and just super grateful but thank
you for that call running I appreciate
it
let's hear another one here we go
Giovanni Boystown for North Carolina
sorry I missed your show man I was on
vacation Tom from North Carolina man
Tom's been a listener since day one of
this podcast now how you even found this
podcast on day one that seemed like he
might be a lurker but I love you Tom and
I appreciate you being here Tom from
rural North Carolina onward it's pretty
much a shame that you have to apologize
they're kind of put a preface before
even an email saying I got in your
feelings and this is kind of making
excuses for it I think that's right huh
um number one issue in my opinion
besides opioids in this country is
mental health okay you know and I
appreciate saying this time you know
it's kind of like I I don't think you're
taking me to task but I feel like you're
bringing up something that's you know
it's so funny I it said that that's how
I felt man you know I was caught up and
I mean I'm happy to let you guys know
means seven days back on my medication
you know and look I wasn't crazy off my
medication I wasn't running around you
know stealing silverware you know and uh
you know um taking furniture apart in my
hotel room last weekend or anything I
just you know I've just been hella
stressed out you know I just been a lot
of traveling a lot of not sleeping and
you start to realize how fragile like
your whatever it is that inside of you
your mainframe your computer your
whatever that it all is all of a sudden
not eating you know I've been losing a
lot of weight just not you know just
been caddywhompus or you know and and so
yeah so then you get you know you're on
a pocket you have to do the podcast you
know you got to show up and then you
find yourself you know basically you're
crying on a podcast you know you find
yourself you know sharing your emotions
I mean you know it definitely I guess I
just hears them here was my thing when I
got back to my hotel room after and had
to finish the second half the podcast I
did I couldn't
usually like you have an idea of like
what's going on in your day how your
life is going what's happening that part
of me was going I was like I don't know
what this even is what that you know I
was just kind of all over the place but
you're right you know so I did feel
weird and I did put a disclaimer you
know and I guess some of that for me is
just you know there's always gonna be
some of that uncomfort level in my life
where yeah it's like I don't know if I
can
I guess you where yah where you're
afraid to share your feelings you know
and I think it's because of how we
accept each other's feelings like like
it's not weird to me if somebody calls
in and has some feelings you know it's
not weird to me at all like I grew up
you know when I remember when I was
young I would give anything to know how
my brother felt you know or how I felt
or how my sister felt we you just
weren't allowed to have any feelings in
my house and so I give anything to know
it and so now I guess I'm in a space
Rogers I want that you know and it's
it's crazy I'm a late bloomer and this
is where I am right now in my life that
I want feeling I want to know what's
going on if I can but yeah you know do I
feel ashamed in uh near Tonasket me I
guess I'm asking myself do I feel
ashamed that I had to put a disclaimer
on the episode I think part of it was I
wanted people to know that I was okay
that I was like you know I wasn't like
you know if you don't take
antidepressants and you don't know kind
of how it feels if you get off from for
a few days you feel like you've been
awake for a couple you get us feel
really you feel uncomfortable you feel
uncomfortable you like you don't have a
shirt on but you're at work that's kind
of what I felt like like [ __ ] man
damn I usually wear a shirt and suddenly
you don't have a shirt on but you're
still at work and so it can be awkward
and that's how I felt and so I guess I
wanted people to know look I'm okay I
just this is how this episode kind of
kicked off onward let's hear more time
and we all have anybody out there talk I
mean we got a few people but like guys
like you who are straight killer comics
to be like hey man like I'm a person the
flaws and this is what emotionally that
really resonates to me more because I
can really feel that you come from well
I'm not trying to fashion a guy but a
guy like Krista
Leigha he comes from Bella parents he
just I'm not that confident guy like I'm
not always like on a hundred percent
like I love myself like there's some
days I'd only more [ __ ] get off you
feel me I really respect that you're out
there putting out a bevy of different
podcast for you know this time I feel my
emotions and I just really feel saying
that you got a almost apologized work
sure there's nothing wrong about this
thing what what makes you feel well yeah
the mole thanks for the call Tom you
know and I don't know like you know
Chris and I are getting closer I don't
know him super well you know so I don't
know I mean he might come off too like
that is you he definitely to me is a
he's a confident guy you know and I wish
a lot of times that I were like him you
know that I wish that I were more
confident um you know I mean if [ __ ]
we're out here you know we're out here
and this is who I am
it's like well I'll always be this
person I don't know you know I mean
sometimes I feel like I'm not doing
enough of the work to you know that I
sometimes too too too much sitting
around in my feelings and I'm not doing
enough of the work to get out of them
you know or to get into a more
comfortable place where I'm learning why
I'm feeling as many ways and some of
that for me is getting back into my
program getting back into my step work
and just generally trying to get
involved in things that you know not
holding on the things that are basically
I'd hold on to some things in my life
out of fear you know I find there's some
relationships I hold on to and my life
out of fear and that's something that's
kind of scary to me sometimes but but
Tom yeah we shouldn't have to be afraid
to have our emotions [ __ ] but look we've
grown up in this society where that's
not really what's going you know hasn't
been the way that things have been you
know women have been more the emotional
ones in the past and now a lot of women
are headed in different directions where
they don't want to be that or you know I
feel like they're being maybe let away
from that that it's not cool to have
that by I think honest about a lot of
you know by some in some good ways but
in something by some false prophets out
there you know false
you know just advertising I think it's
one of the main things that have men you
know it just been a lot of advertising
over the years and make us think oh you
have to be tough you have to do this you
have to do this and that's it
you know can you imagine all the
feelings that died inside of men over
the years if you could go into a
graveyard I'm surprised that ghosts
aren't just emotional you know you
always have these ghosts showing up
haunting people dude if you really
cracked into the bodies of many deceased
people from 3 to 3 4 generations ahead
of before us dawg they would just be all
emo nemo's out there because that's all
they died with most of them just died
full probably of emotions that they
didn't let out but I think we should
teach it in schools how is there not
I've said this before how are there not
classes in schools that teach kids how
to feel and how to react and know how
other kids feel how are people still not
like how are you getting out of class
and not I just don't know but then we
have so many rules and it's just all
these lawyers and all this [ __ ] just
hampering down on our teachers and
everything that they probably are unable
to do a lot of that you know everything
kept we got all [ __ ] up a lot of times
when everybody when everything lawyers
and insurance and all this [ __ ] came
into it I'm not saying if you work for
insurance or if you are a lawyer I'm
just saying that there's this world
where up you felt you know you didn't
get tricked like ah then that's you
gotta have a law and then you have to
have a lawsuit and then the rules change
and it suddenly it's just the point
where nobody's even doing anything like
the if you interact with anybody it's a
lawsuit so that kind of [ __ ] I don't
know I'm time to talking out of my ass
before we take this next call I want to
let you know about go Yaya's Creperie
and coffee down in Baton Rouge Louisiana
they got coffee and they got crepes and
they're at 501 Main Street downtown in
Baton Rouge and now my family lives in
Baton Rouge over there about a chase
bank and my brother and his little son
just had a birthday a little Zephie and
he's sometimes he plays basketball and
he shoots them swaggy shots and he hits
them swaggy buckets but when they are
not shooting buckets they are downtown
at go Yaya's coffee and Creperie and man
if you don't know about crepes you know
about go Yaya's and you're missing out
it's just five minutes from the
Louisiana State University campus they
have breakfast and lunch and not only
dessert crepes not only sweet crepes
they got them hearty hitters they got
them crepes
cone gurth you know what I'm saying them
girth these baby them thick baby legs
you know them crepes got little bit of
girth to them they have breakfast crepes
with bacon eggs and cheese
they got chorizo and eggs with salsa
verde crepes they also have the Acadiana
Bing with local boudin and that pop
roasts grilled cheese but you know what
I'm saying the kind of [ __ ] that'll make
you reconnect with your stepmother right
there they're open Monday to Friday 7:00
a.m. to 1:30 and Saturday 7:30 to noon
you can find them online at go Yaya's
dot-com geo y aya s.com we'll put the
link tell them that I sent you say hello
to my friend David all right let's take
another call here thank you guys for
calling hey vo it's Tim up in Canada
this past weekend I just got into your
podcast I just want you to know I love
you you know I'm gonna get emotional
thanks for calling Tim appreciated me
and that's okay to get emotional man I
feel you bro homeward I'm in my third
year of sobriety as well and the AAA
program is the thing I love so much
about you the thing that I admire so
much about you this thing that I'm sure
all this depressed anxious sober
alcoholics out here love about you is
that you're more you now then when
you're out to actively use it I just
love how silly and fun you are and I
want to bring that part of me out I know
it's in there and I don't know I felt
like I was more that when when I was
drinking I am happier than I've ever
been I really am but I want the outside
guy to match the inside to me I want to
get in there anyway I love you and I
love this podcast
you will help me so much I'm just so
grateful that you're a part of my life
thanks for help me get that hitter
thanks bro you got me [ __ ] emo doubt
man that's okay bro you know [ __ ] dude
you know uh I mean it sounded like look
you just made me laugh at the moment of
you know were you sharing your feelings
you know it is pretty powerful you know
it's like so many times I would drink or
I would I mean I didn't drink much but I
think a lot of times it seems like we
drink or we party or we do something
because we just feel like we're not
enough you know and it's funny when
you're young we drink or party or you
know or whatever have fun because it's
kind of part of culture but then for
some of us or for me anyway I guess it
it just it was it was doing so it was
something that I was doing when I'm
because whatever you know I wasn't
enough yeah it's like we just want to be
it's brave man think how brave it is
some people think you know you're you're
sober that's [ __ ] up or that's weak
you know or that's what dude I think
it's brave I think it's the hardest
thing to do to go and be so - oh you
know what oh we got all these things
that help us have fun and this and that
but I'm gonna walk out here by myself
son I'm just gonna walk out here do you
have any booze all I got is whatever you
know the Lord is you know put in my
veins you know I got nine pints of
[ __ ] o+ that's all the liquid courage
I got I me and the crazy thing is we get
used to it you know we get used to being
sober in it it's actually relaxing at a
lot of times to go to a place and not
have to drink not after party as [ __ ] is
sometimes relaxing but thanks man you
know you saying that it makes you know
that it seem like I have fun and stuff
like that you know I appreciate that
dude because I want to you know you know
I want to live my
that's life I want to live you don't
want to like you know I want to be able
you know I want to I don't know I can't
figure out what I'm trying to say but
you made me laugh maybe you made me
laugh you know what's funny is I'll tell
you this time whenever um let me make
sure that it's Tim - sorry man sometimes
huh hey deal it's Tim up in Canada okay
good yeah sometimes Tim I noticed when
dude if I start talking say somebody
else like we're talking about is sober
some or whatever we're talking about
drugs or partying we start talking on a
crazy story dude by the if I want to
party if I want to go party I'm having
feeling like I want a party or something
if I tell a crazy story with somebody
else and they tell me a crazy story and
we laugh and have a good time as soon as
we're don't laughing and having a good
time I don't want a party anymore
because of what I really wanted was I
didn't want a party what I really wanted
was to connect with somebody and have
fun and feel good you know and I wanted
somebody else to like I wanted to feel
okay and I wanted to be I wanted I
wanted to be around somebody and have
them be okay and then be around me and
me be okay and everything was okay
everything was okay and I didn't walk
away feeling like all [ __ ] you know I I
said there's this something they didn't
do there that is or we didn't or I
didn't or somebody you know something I
didn't none of that everybody was just
okay and that's really all I wanted ever
my whole life was just to to have a
conversation or a moment with somebody
and leave and everybody be okay and so
that's what I noticed the sobriety does
for me is that I'll have those moments
you know if I feel like party and I have
a moment of okayness or somebody we
laugh boom we're good and onward bruh
and onward but you're welcome man and
thanks for being a part of this podcast
man and thanks for listening and thank
you for calling in Tim out there in
Saskatoon baby and dude Saskatoon sounds
like a bar how could you not drink out
there brother but I think you're doing a
good job man
you made me laugh for us so if you don't
think you're there I mean
I would I could kind of fathom but you
aren't halfway there
so onward let's hear another call that
came in who listens who listens to the
podcast we got a couple of calls that
came in here here we go
hey I was just watching one of the
podcast and you wanted to know who
they're from
yes I do and you have a beautiful voice
young lady onward I'm in New Mexico I
don't know if I'm a ghost
because how do you know I guess you
wouldn't know maybe you know I could be
an asexual ghost I don't know
but really I run and I like to actually
I'm involved in the circus I do aerial
trapeze and you do a lot seem like all
my fabric and I just wanted to say I
listened to your podcast a mortgage
underwriter I run I do CrossFit I like
to paint and my name is Sarah
I um I love what to do thank you Sarah
thanks for calling in look sometimes you
want to know who and you don't know who
listen so you don't who this and next
thing you know it's an underwriting
goats it's a ghost that does
underwriting and also runs so look I'll
tell you this there it's nice to know
when I was growing up ghosts weren't
doing [ __ ] they were being scared or
they were scaring people and that was it
you know a couple of them had gigs on
television you know Casper did and then
somebody onion maybe one other ghost you
know Ichabod Crane or whatever but
outside of that they wasn't doing [ __ ]
but now it's nice to know ghosts are
running ghosts are working mortgage
underwriting doing Crossfit so thank you
for listening to the podcast and very
interesting young lady Thank You Sara
let's hear more hey Co I'm calling from
Dubai I'm out here in the desert oasis
Dubai boy and Dubai seems great do TV
and I never been in Dubai we
a man that called in last week actually
uh scar and he was out in Dubai and he
showed some video of some footage of it
in our YouTube you can see it but man it
seems crazy a beach without water
everybody out there to legal to drink
you know I'm sure they got some hookers
out there some straight ups and hookers
you know what I'm saying why some of
that warm poo Tang being sold around
town or that warm cat CAC I mean that's
crazy man
everybody dehydrated selling dehydrated
crotch to each other who was wild out
there thank you for calling sir workin
out here for about a year a little bit
I'm a lawyer actually originally from
Canada Canada's great more so I just
wanted to let you know that those people
listen to you from all over the world
different walks of life people doing
different things but we can all relate
to a lot of things you're talking about
so I appreciate you keep doing what
you're doing and good luck hopefully we
can get you out here to buy some time
think about it Gang Gang
oh-ho we snuck that GG and at the end
what they sneaking around out there and
them sandcastles man he's an attorney
out there and Dubai why that's cool man
thanks for calling in you know it's
funny that I when I was young I wanted
to be an attorney you know when you're a
kid or when I was a kid that was like
the thing you could be man the rich that
seemed like you'd be like a rich person
you know or you'd be able to do things
and I feel bad I was just making fun of
attorneys a little bit ago and not
everyone's you know I mean a lot of this
is generalizations so and also look I
don't know what the [ __ ] I'm talking
about
so but if you took offense to something
you know feel free to hit the hotline
and let me know and but thank you for
calling and thanks for listening
at least I know if I do get in trouble
somewhere and internationally
bye-bye ow I got your phone number so
thank you so much let's get into a
little bit of um oh we got these weekend
contests people have called in about the
best weekend that they had or the worst
weekend you can hit the hotline whenever
you want nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three and let us know if
you had a great or worst weekend but
make sure it's a greater worse
don't call him with some regular last
weekend you know I'm saying like Terry
you know like big Terry got her tubes
tied we don't give a heck you know I'm
saying if now she got him tied by
somebody who does you know like a clown
that does those cool balloon animals now
that's a unique person you get your
tubes tied by isn't it
um word let's hear one hey Theo I'll
make it quick this is for the best
weekend entry from fifty years old I
competed in my first you Jitsu
tournament a weekend ago went down with
my girlfriend 27 year old blue belt in
jujitsu I'm a white belt I've been doing
it for just about a year wow look at Tim
and he snuck the agent of his lady to
there you heard him slip that age in you
know my girl 27 year old
congratulations Timothy already sounds
like an amazing weekend man you guys are
both doing jiu-jitsu you're at 50 years
age man let's hear more
we both competed she got gold and in
know--he and bronze and ghee and look I
don't condone the word the use of the
word noogie okay I don't know what Tim's
talking about but um you know Neoga we
can discuss but just joking homework and
then I got silver in my division
I've been doing jujitsu for about a year
and it's uh changed my life man it's the
best thing I ever did the girl and I we
spent the weekend together first time
we've taken a trip I I got like you you
got that shy [ __ ] sometimes and uh but
for the weekend it if it behaves and
performed and that was a good point too
and there's just I got to say if one of
the best weekend's I've had this girl
freaks me out and I'm 50 she's 27 but
there's a real connection between she
and I and I might end up marrying the
growing put the baby in her there too
dang man talking about jiu-jitsu that's
over that's a finishing move right there
put that baby in there you know what I'm
saying you know what I'm saying that's
that arm you know
that's that leglock that that'll last
for nine months
Wow well that's cool look man I'm glad
you guys had a great time a lot of new
stuff one of them we especially when you
going to the first trip with somebody
you're dating that's always kind of a
fun thing you know and y'all you know
y'all crews often do something new
together in a new place that's an
exciting time I'm glad you guys got to
have that experience and it sounds like
it went good or it went well that's what
my mother would say she would correct me
you know as you're you're talking about
I'm thinking about this that Tim while
you're talking the 50 in the 27-year you
know it's interesting yeah you know
who's to say what's okay you know who's
to say what age is okay like I mean you
know my father was 70 when I was born my
mother was 32 and my father didn't have
any money you know I mean I mean I've
said it before I might [ __ ] old do
with some cash you know what I'm saying
let's see how my career goes but um or
see what kind of tough nuts I ended up
in I won't [ __ ] I do I mean you know if
we were both in the dark or something he
was erect and there was money definitely
outside of the door I might jerk that
dude out you know but that's nature is
that nurture that's nature that's nature
because you don't learn and do that
you're born knowing you're able to do
that if you need that money but but yeah
man you know the age difference
sometimes it's it is what it is you know
I think it's just a matter of if it's a
healthy situation and I'm not sure I'm
not judging your situation or anything
like that I'm just it's got me thinking
about that you know it's got me thinking
about that because I think there's a lot
of fear out there for men and women
there's a lot of fear for men of you
know I feel like a lot of my friends are
worried about marrying women the same
age as them and then there's a lot of
fear for women you know this is a
there's probably this pressure out there
that it feels like you have to marry
somebody that is uh already fiscally
well-off you know are stable or maybe
women just want stability I don't know I
should probably get somebody that knows
more about like genders and how they
behave and stuff in here some
and we could talk with him about that I
look forward to doing that thanks for
calling Tim let's hear another one oh it
actually you know what I want to think
about this i watch the I watched that
Poirier Alvarez fight this weekend and
if you're not familiar with these two
but these two bad boys they are UFC
prize fighters and these I mean these
are the kind of dudes I'll tell you this
I wouldn't take their daughter on a date
you know I'm saying these are some real
bad boys you know and they're good guys
but they you know they're Romans they're
you know they're guys they're finishing
one of these dudes will probably might
fight a tiger in a few years or some on
the internet for a big purse you know
the other kind of these these are some
you know these are some real hitters and
both of them are lightweights but I
wouldn't tell them that but they're
ranked number four and three and on the
charts you know in that lightweight UFC
chart so their chart neighbors bra their
you know their chart neighbors so you
know that this fight was gonna be a real
you know a real fiasco you know what I'm
saying this thing I mean and people were
fired up cuz they fought before they
already fought one time and they were
coming back for more so here's the thing
dude I remember most of the people I
ever fought beat my ass bruh
and so I I'm cool you know I'm saying if
people are like you want to go back from
war I'll be like I'm good but these
gentlemen these bad battleships want her
to straight up you know they wanted to
swim in each other's ocean again and so
this was a Poirier Alvarez part too and
you got Eddie Alvarez man and this guy
Eddie Alvarez
I mean it's him I keep him fighting his
whole life I mean it look it looks like
he don't even sleep like he just stays
up all night and fights you know this
guy is you want to talk about somebody
that seem like they just absolute a
gentleman of the sport and I don't mean
gentle in the word gentle I mean a
leatherneck but I'm talking about a the
a concierge of the sport you know this
man you know he just I mean it's just
he's a he's a he's a technician you can
tell that he loves it is in him
you know and it's not in him like a
fever some of these guys this fight
seems like it's in them like a fever but
mr. Eddie Alvarez it seems like it is in
him at a level that is that is technical
as well and and mr. Dustin Poirier he's
out of Louisiana you know he's out of
the Louisiana that party a so he's seen
you know that Poirier so it seemed like
by the time you even said his name it
seemed like you just like you've already
French kissed the air just saying his
name you know mr. Poirot a you know it
seemed like you and the air might
already you know be ready for a second
date but here you go man these two bad
boys are going at it and I tuned in to
this one man I don't tune in a lot of
the fights but I love watching Louisiana
fighters and Poirier out of Lafayette
but based on a Coconut Creek down in
Florida and I'm a big fan of both him
and mr. Cormier so this fight starts out
and they just testing each other out but
they're fast about it you know sometime
you watch these UFC fights and he's you
know they barely touch each other the
first round they're just looking at each
other you know some of it seem like it's
like kind of dirty ballet that you might
pay extra for and watch in like the
basement of like a New York kind of like
you know some like shady place in New
York or in like downtown Toledo or
something but these two boys man they
got in the ring and immediately they was
you know they was starting to figure it
out it was almost like they were just
they picked up right from where their
last fight ended you know and at a
certain point you see kind of like
Alvarez kind of does this spin move and
then Poirier kind of jumps into him but
doesn't do anything and that part to me
kind of reminding me of you ever like
started playing xbox and you didn't know
how to use the control and you're just
trying the buttons out that's what it
kind of seemed like to me like you see
like Alvarez like okay this is what uh
this is what the right push right does
and then um you you see pori is like
okay this one jumps but I oh I forgot to
press kick so like you kind of see him
like kind of testing out all their moves
you know and you see Poirier he's got
them si got snakes in his arms do not
bet if you looked around his
neighborhood over there in Coconut Creek
and you check the arm you know pet-store
missing pets I bet they got a couple of
cottonmouths missing I bet they got a
couple of dangerous cottonmouth snakes
that are missing and I bet if you look
inside of his arms you'll find a couple
of snakes because that man he got that
arm comes out in their [ __ ] bite at
the end that thing comes out hard and
straight bro you know and it might be
cottonmouth but it's like about 9,000
percent cotton you know he got that
[ __ ] hard cottonmouth to walk and
their mix ended up in no homo here but
Eddie's got that beautiful body I mean
Eddie Alvarez if you looking at Eddie I
mean he looked like you know I don't
think he barely on he may have one
tattoo doesn't look like yeah any but
he's got that I mean he could be like a
model and like Miami model hats model
cigars you know like he seemed like that
got Donna you know he's got that you
know he's got that couple where I on him
you know he's got that Miami handsome
you know and these boys they're going at
it they go at it hard it's not like it
means you know like I said some of these
fights start out solved but these boys
go at it immediately you know like a
couple of ham hunters you know when they
heard that the winner of this fight gets
that best cut a ham you know the and
that they swing it for good ham you know
I'm saying these ain't no these ain't no
butterball you know these ain't no
butterball bad boys these some honey
baked hunters you know what I'm saying
they're going for those good hits
because they want that that you know I'm
saying they're going for that top prize
now they keep cruising on and using
different tactics here and you see Eddie
Alvarez there's this moment where he you
kind of he kind of goes for four
Dustin's waist and it's like he tries to
I don't feel for seen like a kidnapper
at a mall when they try to rush somebody
and push them into a van but he goes for
that you know that kidnapper into the
van kind of thrust waist move and then
he backs out of it when Dustin kind of
slips out and and then Dustin kind of
counters a little later you see him with
this you know he kind of do this you
know it's like the stanky leg but it's
with his arm it's kind of like you ever
seen that move where somebody's kind of
looking for a light switch in the dark
that's kind of that you know it's kind
of like if you have been looking for a
light switch in the dark it's like you
don't know where it is but you still out
there you know you got that it's kind of
like a metal to
Tector when you put in that arm out in
front like that wild metal detector and
it's ineffective but he's also he's just
kind of you know both these guys are
still kind of feeling each other out at
this point and at the end of the first
round it's this thing is the crowd is
into it there's a fervor and uh and
Alvarez is throwing them cat strikes you
know you ever spent time around a cat
and a cat sometime you think oh we're
friends this cat likes me you kind of
pet that cat or suddenly you think it's
just rest and and suddenly that cattle
just [ __ ] you up like that and that's
like Alvarez
you know Alvarez you think he's being
complacent or something you you you let
him for a second think that he's getting
you know getting tired or anything and
then BAM bruh that [ __ ] cat strike
you know so they rasslin you know and
they rasslin wildly and then Poirier
gets him in that headlock Poirier
suddenly you know they were there round
and about and they're touching each
other's bodies really aggressively and
next you know Poirier 'he's got him in
that hard scarf poor he's got him in
that hard [ __ ] scarf boy and that
things about thirty thousand percent
cotton bruh and in sixteen thousand
percent wool and that's the hardest
scarf you ever could even be in and you
don't think that um that alvarez is
gonna get out of it but alvarez kind of
right you know he keeps his airway open
enough and i don't know enough technic
technically what did a lot of these
things are called and i'm have to ask
Eddie Bravo whenever I talked to him a
little bit more about this fight so he
can take me through it and look I'm not
I'm not trying to make fun of these that
either one of these men would could whip
my ass probably in their sleep yeah
maybe even in a coma both these men
could whip my ass but you see that all
that Poirier hasn't been that hard scarf
and this war alvarez flips the script
you know he slips out of that hard scarf
and next thing you know he's got poor
ray up against the cage and he's really
and this for me this this got a little
bit you know a little crotchy you know
it seemed like and look I know you use
every element it seems like these men
are warriors
these men are Roman warriors and but it
seemed like a little bit of like the me
to movement kind of it seemed like you
know Poirier was kind of
like it almost seemed like you know
maybe a cop should show up and just you
know make sure this ain't a damn
domestic dispute because it was just
this thing seemed a little crotch heavy
you know like suddenly my gay friends
were like oh this seems interesting when
before they hadn't been paying attention
to the television and this is the part
where they separate him because Eddie
hits him with that arm with that elbow
straight down the 12th to 6 they called
it you can't do that 12 to 6 that
trucker you know you remember when you
were a kid and you were driving along
the interstate and you were looking out
the window or your parents are driving
you'd look out the window you'd see a
trucker and some of them would try to
[ __ ] show you their junk or whatever
get you to you know show show your
nipples to them but the decent ones you
could go like this and they would just
pull their horn you know and that's the
only interaction you guys had and that's
what uh Eddie hits him with that [ __ ]
you know with that decent truck or horn
pull and the referee says you can't do
it you can't do that 12 to 6 you call
them you have to come in at an angle and
I didn't even know that about the fights
so I'm learning something new right
there and right after that man it really
you know honestly I couldn't even tell
exactly what was happening because the
strikes just came fast there's a knee
there's a couple of hand strikes and
Alvarez step man that guy you know he
lost Poirier took him and kept hitting
him and I thought there was a point
where I thought that the fight was over
and Alvarez still throwing punches you
know and that's when it's just so it's
amazing to see how deep and engrained it
is into some of these men to be able to
fight and to be able to be warriors
I mean Alvarez almost reminds me of like
a character from gladiator or something
like that you know he very much has that
I think he could even have an acting
career you know he just had when you see
him you see that but I was happy that uh
you know that Poirier took it on him you
know drops a couple hits and Poirier May
he could see in his eyes his eyes go
full pupil you know what I'm saying his
eyes go full pupil in that second you're
like wow this man I mean just so zoned
in and so effortless to
so effortless you know and the UFC
definitely grows on me more and more
especially as I you know get more
tempted to try out like Brazilian
jiu-jitsu myself did I'd never be in a
damn fight man
I couldn't handle myself but it would be
but watching these men in there and
seeing them get excited and seeing I
mean I feel excited even just talking
about this [ __ ] you know but the UFC
definitely grows on me because I
realized yes it is fighting yes they are
going against each other but also
there's such a there's such a
camaraderie and there's such a you know
there's such a mat there's such a level
of respect because even as as a fan you
mean you just have so much respect for
these guys just watching they're able to
do that and the fear not just to be
fearless of it you know to go out there
most men it's a huge feat they say
public speaking is most most people's
biggest fear I think it's fighting to go
out there and fight and these men go out
there and do it but it was you know much
respect to both of these men I would say
I was happy to see Poirier win you know
just see a guy from Louisiana and you
know what this fight reminded me of just
a great bar fight if it reminded me of
two of like the best bar fighters you've
ever heard of finally showed up at the
same happy hour and uh and hats off to
both of those guys man hats off to both
of them let's cruise into another call
or two here oh we got another weekend
contest that came in here we go yeah
North Carolina is just stink I don't
know if I heard that name right
and I don't want to say someone's name
is stink but it could be a nickname Oh
word stink taller than for ID on both
weekend or worst weekend I'll let you be
the judge last weekend went out for the
bar on Saturday night and met this girl
she's out with some friends and her
friends got very drunk and she was there
by herself and this girl was nine months
pregnant okay so
she's out there you know being that
Sherpa let's hear more come to find out
just found out that baby daddy's been
cheating on her
yeah ended up wow man it's got to be
pretty sad you know oh and she's at a
bar nine months pregnant
hmm that's phase that feminism I don't
know what that is
what do you do though when you're not I
mean it's probably better than her
sitting at home by herself you know good
for her go for her getting out and doing
something you know staying active let's
hear more hooking up with her taking her
back to my place she stayed the whole
weekend with me what I did not side it
should not expect this part of this what
I did not expect this part this part of
this man damn he took home that not
ma'am ro you took home a nine month
pregnant woman with the baby is right
brother only that's almost like having a
baby in the room bruh no there's only a
couple inches between you and a live
baby you know I'm saying there's only
like eight layers of skin between you
and a live baby being in the room that
baby's pretty much in the room but it's
just hiding you realize that huh Wow
let's hear more and then Monday after
she left I got a text on this you just
popped out that little baby that when
the visitor at the hospital says
congratulations you know wow man this is
damn this is like Bridges of Madison
County a little bit you know this is
like dang this this is this is like the
notebook but in in Sacramento let's hear
a little bit more man this is pretty
sweet kind of feel like my big help do
this but man every time I think that
this conversation is going to be a
certain way and you you turn it a
different way
onward yeah man this is it weekend you
know
have a good one Wow so you met a girl at
the bar nine months and you popped it
you helped her maybe have a baby you're
basically a midwife you know I'm saying
you're like a midwife do what if you
were a mid husband you're like a dude
that finds women that are pregnant that
are just about to have a baby and you
got that magical keg you you got that
hitter you know you got that wild little
hitter and you got that thing that helps
them all just you know you got that um
they call you the water breaker and
you're out there and it's like um it's
almost like Kevin Costner could play you
if there was ever a movie but they call
you the water breaker and you get out
there and help women come come to full
term and you're finishing move is the is
the the third trimester and you're the
water breaker that's cool man well I
guess you did something good man it's a
way to give back and you went to visit
her and the baby that's sweet of you you
know I mean I look you're a gentleman in
my book and I know you're not asking me
if you are but that if they don't sound
like a great weekend man I don't know
what is I do not know what it is at all
I gotta make a phone call real fast all
right let's get into another couple of
calls here sorry I just had a little uh
I had to take a little bite of that
lakeside make Bowl here we go hey Theo
von I want to know how do you be funny
without being an [ __ ] I feel like
whenever oh that's a good question man
there's a good question thank you for
calling about this more I get in like a
joking mood I just tear other people
down or like complain about [ __ ] or just
like make fun of other people in general
or I'm like complaining about something
and that's when I feel funny I know you
said used to be real angry in the
beginning but I just wanted to know what
you thought about that all right man I
love the show bye thanks for calling man
love you bruh you
and I did I used to be that way man and
sometimes I still have to be careful
that I don't and yeah it was just anger
it was just anger you don't wanted to
make people laugh but I was just man I
was just angry you know I was just angry
and so if you if you're asking me that
question you're probably noticing a lot
in yourself and so you I had to get into
an emotionally better place you know I
thought that the world was against me a
lot of times and I here's the here's the
crazy thing and this gonna be hard or
for me this is really hard is I didn't
realize that somebody could have told me
right now with you what I'm telling
somebody could have said to me right now
what I'm saying to you and it wouldn't
have I wouldn't be able to recognize it
like oh I feel like the world is against
me but but because I did about it I
didn't recognize it
yep I feel like the world was against me
and it wasn't and once I realized that
the world was not against me then I
could still be funny because I was still
funny you know and I'm not trying to
toot my own horn here but you know it
was what I like to do you know I was
still I was still had a you know a hint
of humor you know but now the world
wasn't against me and so I could lay my
jokes better out into the world they
didn't have to be at you know it wasn't
coming from a place of defense now my
brain and my heart could be funny in a
way or sometimes it wasn't always at a
place of offense it was a myth it was a
place of just kind of from everywhere
and that and also people can tell when
you have ill ill inside of you when they
can feel that ill intent inside of you
they can tell it they can feel it we and
we feel it in ourselves man sometimes I
still notice man I'm joking around too
much and I'm getting back into my old
ways and it's not fair and I owe this
person maybe an apology or at least to
let them know hey I'm sorry or I'll have
a little a carburetor in my mind or a
little um
what does it call when you set the
throttle no the idle I have an idol in
my mind they'll let me know uh you're
running hot right now you got to just
just be quiet
you know just tone it down but once I
realized that the world wasn't against
me then I wasn't as defensive and so I
wasn't uh my first line of humor wasn't
a defensive one it wasn't an attack one
no I got to make fun of that person now
it's still fun sometimes now some people
like it when you make fun of them like
Brendan Schaub and if you don't know him
he is a you know he was a wrestler and
he retired and he you know he's a model
he's kind of a model I guess a little
kind of thick to be a model I think but
whatever but he is a podcast host and a
big fighter big brown fighter and he has
yeah he has the fighter and the kid you
know that TF ATK and he also has the big
brown fighter and that's where they talk
about different fights and uh but he um
he he likes it when you rip him up when
you roast him so with him it's more fun
but yeah I'm I you got to be careful
sometimes for me I would notice too if I
was doing it a bunch in a row like if I
was making like if I made a joke about
somebody sometimes would be okay the
first or second time the third time the
start to and that's when you're being
meaning you're picking on somebody and
and now if you do do that that you can
always go back and apologize you know so
and sometimes the apology is you know
I've learned a lot of my life
apologizing I've learned a lot even when
I didn't think that I was wrong you know
I've learned a lot about in my life
about apologizing because if you go to
somebody who [ __ ] you over right say
you think somebody [ __ ] you over and
you go to him and you you hit them with
an apology you hit them with some kind
of a kindness you do something man that
puts them in a crazy space because now
somewhere inside of them they know that
they're wrong and it just you start to
and you start to infect that whatever
that in them let's some lesson behave
that way you start to infect that with
something good
all right let's take another call here
hey Bo my name is Danny Vargas from
Denver Colorado thanks for calling -
Colin just say thank you obviously for
what to do your podcast make me really
happy and some time right here but my
question I guess my issue that I won't
bring up and when you get give your
piggy gage your insight is that but I've
got out of five year relationship and
it's pretty tough sometimes and you know
I I'm trying to be healthy and work out
you know vitamins socialize and all that
but at the end of the day it's full at
the end day you still go to sleep in
you're sad or whatever but in just a few
hiding inside your advice that you could
give are any experiences that you've had
to appreciation for them keep on doing
what you're doing
love you love you - Daniel thanks for
calling in man yeah dude that is hectic
huh I'm sorry bruh you know I'm sorry -
you feeling like that I'm sorry yeah
then breaks up the breaks ups are tough
and if you get out of out of a break I
have a breaks up you it's hard even if
you know it's the right thing you know
you and if you know it's best it still
it still hurts you know the worst part
for me I remember man when I was young
boy and things were so much more severe
when I be in a breakup all I could do
and this is back I mean and I still I
still struggle with this a lot you know
I used to love
I used to my girlfriend's the
girlfriends that I chose or the ones
that would you know be my girlfriend ah
the second they were my girlfriend they
became like my mother you know it became
that and so you know I loved I you know
I would just so when we broke up
for me it felt like I'm loss of a mother
you know because I put all these
different expectations on them that
weren't really fair to them I put on the
you know it's just you know and that's
my own problems and I still suffer from
that a lot you know I still suffer from
that I'll fall in love and make a mother
out of out of a girlfriend and that's
just trippy you know that's just trippy
Anna and that's some of the work that I
still need to do on myself to get in a
better space but but not to make this
about me
the that's that's hectic and things you
could do some of it is honestly just to
feel it you know because sometimes about
things about feelings the reason why we
feel them for so long sometimes it's
good we don't feel them at all you know
we mask them or hide them or feel them
you know it it hurts to lay in you know
[ __ ] I'll tell you this [ __ ] I remember
being real lonely laying in my bed and I
remember like kicking my leg out across
the bed it's under the covers and
nobody's over there and that's just
sometimes you know especially as you get
upward in your 30s like damn that's her
that hurts you know am I always it was
my life always gonna always gonna be
just me you know when you get out of a
relationship you're like aw man cuz
there's a lot of comfort there a lot of
people I think stay in relationships
cause of coz of comfort and you know
what that's okay I think because it's
hard to find some comfort in your life
if you and someone you know you're not
gonna be in love every second of every
day I don't care who it is I don't care
if it's a family member or anybody I
don't feel like you are gonna so you
know some people stay in love because
they're stay in a relationship because
it's just that there's that comfort you
know and say yeah you're gonna be
without that comfort man you're gonna be
out there you're like an astronaut we
don't have a suit on so you're really
probably pretty raw and exposed to the
elements but do you know I'm saying out
there start thinking about other planets
you know start maybe looking at the
rings on that Saturn over there you know
what I'm sayin boy
you know sneaking in your buddy's mom's
house and take a hit off that Brasi air
baby but just know this man you ain't
alone and you could probably bring that
up to almost any dude or any even any
woman and talk to him about it but if
you feel something [ __ ] say how you
feel you know and I appreciate you
calling here and bringing it up man
you're here man you're here with us but
are you good
we good man you know I'm saying I come
over there [ __ ] your breath I had a
vagina for your breath you know and if I
was in there that kind of [ __ ] who knows
maybe if the world's gonna end bruh you
might live next door to some smoking-hot
chick or something and maybe the world's
gonna in next week and you got like you
know there's an announcement that comes
on the news like two minutes - the world
ends dude have your best shirt pressed
right by the door put that [ __ ] on it's
gonna take you about 18 seconds get out
in the hallway it's gonna probably take
you 12 seconds to run back in your
apartment realize you got to put a mint
in all right now you get back to her
door you got about a minute and 20
seconds left to be alive
I would ring the doorbell off have one
don't knock
sometimes you knock and you don't know
if they heard it and maybe they didn't
hear it and I can take another 20
seconds wasted to ring the doorbell now
she's gonna show up you got about a
minute and five seconds dude - take that
party straight to [ __ ] town and she's
gonna want to because the world's ending
but I would just tell her like look you
know I've been in love and sometimes I
miss it or hey man I wonder what do we
feel like if you and me got comfortable
dude it's gonna take y'all probably 35
seconds to get somewhere we all can [ __ ]
and get your clothes off
but for that last 35 dude you're gonna
be a couple of damn donkeys that have
just been lightly electrocuted y'all
gonna be straight [ __ ] and that's
beautiful all right man let's take
another call thank you for calling in
though brother I appreciate you let's
take another call hey Theo this is Ruben
comic-con Phoenix Arizona what's up
Ruben my mother used to live out there
outside of Phoenix man in
Glendale and and I love Arizona man I
love that state you know into University
of Arizona for a little bit and I used
to live out there off of a east side out
on the east side on out in Tucson you
know out of way out off of Golf Links
watching people box outside of the car
washes brah onward and I'm sitting here
man and I'm just I'm listening to your
podcast you know the emo emo and it's
really crazy man because you have a very
very special way of communicating your
thoughts it's very unique and it's very
it's very special thanks dude I
appreciate you calling the saying that
Ruben let's hear more and before I even
before I listened to the podcast I
grabbed before I wasn't having a good
day myself and I was being an emo emo
and when I heard you say that man is
like please don't marry me
can you look man you just flipped
something me because it is kind of a
ridiculous term isn't it but it is kind
of I guess it is oddly kind of weird
it's like what we do sometimes we just
kind of uh start swimming around in our
own feelings you know it's one of the
curses of comfort in America sometimes
it's one of the curses of comfort is
that we can sometimes on a whole America
we're pretty comfortable and we then
when you start to not have problems in
front of you soon when you start to look
at the look for problems inside of you
or we get you know our emotions are kind
of like our new frontier you know it
used to be you would go off into the
woods with your tribe and that was the
frontier and now our frontier you know
the woods have kind of moved inside of
us let's hear more Ruben thank you so I
continue to listen to the podcast man
like you know I'm laughing and you have
a very like a few times where I've
listened to the podcast and you have a
very special way of being able to make
somebody smile like laughs or just like
trip out and the things that you say in
the way you explain
everything the very unique man you're
very special you have a huge fan over
here in Phoenix Arizona
thanks Ruben thanks for the nice words
may not you know I've got a lot of nice
calls as well I wish I could play them
all you know I wish I could play all the
nice calls and just you know people just
checking in man I can't even tell you
you know you know thank you so much you
know this makes me think a little bit
you know when you know this thing this
makes me think a little bit Ruben as
you're saying that you know I do find
that I you know I'm glad that you that
you think I have a you know a go at
communicating and you know it's this
some of this goes back to you know a lot
of the hemopneumo stuff it was coming
you know it was just you know I was
thinking about my mother and I wanted to
go see this college that she was that
she went to and it made me feel bad that
I didn't go you know I didn't I honestly
didn't make it more of a priority no
matter what was going on in my life you
know I didn't make sure I was well
rested the week before that I was taking
my meth you know it just things I didn't
do
I didn't do certain things so I could be
there and be in a comfortable situation
and go and take care of my response you
know take care of things I wanted to do
I wanted to go see the school and mom
went to you know because I saw education
is important to her and I didn't get to
do it but you know a lot of this stuff
communication it goes back to I think
you know my mother and I've never I've
said this before we never like have like
laugh together you know and we were a
kid we never laughed together you know
she and I think her parents didn't laugh
with her you know so she didn't know it
she didn't know you can do that sort of
thing she didn't there was nothing in
her world that that's how you connected
with your children and and so I think as
a kid all I ever wanted to do I've said
this before but all I ever wanted to do
and why I probably communicate some
other ways that are funny or
entertaining I think all I ever wanted
to do when I was a kid was make my mom
laugh
you know I wanted to make her feel good
you know I wanted to make her feel
comfort you know I wanted to look at her
and not see her like having to work hard
and having a struggle and having to
having her like I wanted to see her
without concern you know I wanted to
just see her you know with joy in her
and so I think even when I was young
even not even knowing it you know not
even any plan Aman but I would try
probably a million different ways to
make her laugh you know our ways you
know in probably different ways of
communicating because to make her feel
okay or just to make her feel or make
her seem any different than she was to
get her out of whatever this cage of
just you know uh effort she was all
she's always me my mother's my mother is
alive my mother's you know 75 years old
I think she's always putting forth
effort you know she still works every
single you know she just it never ends
you know it never ends she's never
stopped working you know we've never
really gotten to hang out and all I ever
wanted to do was to have her I just
wanted to find somehow if I can figure
out this communication if I can figure
out a way to get to her she'll know that
that I just want her to laugh so I can
be okay you know when you see your
mother laugh as a kid to let you know
that everything is okay so anyhow if I'm
if I if I communicate in different ways
I think is because I think when I was
young I just tried as many way you know
I was just trying to pick that lock of
wanting to laugh with my mom and but I
appreciate you calling it about that
Ruben this it's nice out pretty you you
know helping me think about that and
help me you know anytime I get to think
about my mother it makes me feel good
you know and uh you know I wished that
arm
you know something you know what's crazy
as I wish that people could feel how we
feel about them wouldn't that be awesome
wouldn't it be a great in the future of
that like a virtual reality I wish it
was an emotional one
you know man wouldn't that be great and
you know what's funny is I think we
honestly have that in us I think it's
just our instincts you know it's just
that's an emotional virtual reality I
kind of don't know what I'm saying about
it maybe I kind of do I don't know but
thank you for calling Reuben M word I
said homeward and that was the end of
the call
let's take let's take another call here
thank you for calling what deal just you
talking about networks pushing 30
comedians and yes it's becoming
increasingly easier to not think survive
today's society you just get pushed into
these jobs and get pushed into buying
these products and you get bullied
around pretty much by these major media
markets major media entities and some
people fall into it some people don't
and just a fad just the fact that you
think that you're thinking and sometimes
you lost in your own thoughts whatever
but dude that's just to think that
that's that's what that's what separates
you from some other people and you know
I mean it's not for everybody thinking
it it's harder it's a lot harder than
[ __ ] swimming with pool you know it
it uh it is funny cuz I'm not somebody
ask you a question do you'll be like
[ __ ] you don't want to think about it
you know I think my for me a lot of my
brain is really started to manifest
itself in my emotions or so
to live into my emotions or into you
know my brain is almost in my skin more
than it is in my head sometimes or it's
in my heart sometimes I don't know
what's going on but you know I get
inspired I get inspired to think by some
of these other people you know we have
jordan peterson stopped through here we
have Jaco willings coming in and soon
you know I get inspired by thinkers
because I say this man I believe quickly
that the world is starting to separate
and I believe that it is going to be in
the end a lot of people think it's going
to be the rich and the poor I don't
believe that but I do believe that it's
going to be the thinkers and the and the
non thinkers you know I do believe that
because some people it's generational
you just gets your beer you get so true
you're so in the next thing you know
it's two three four generations and
there's nothing there's not a dishonor
or an original thought left hand
somebody or even a question the idea to
wonder to question you know and I said
look we are unknown and none of us are
perfect I mean but I it's man it's one
of the blessings of getting into this
podcast has been I get around guys like
you know Joe Rogan I'm sitting there
talking to him backstage or something at
the con and he's like well what do you
think about that when your friends ask
you what do you think what do you think
what do you feel about that you know and
I'm a little bit more what do you feel
than what do you think but it's it's
awareness and I'm noticing more for
myself that I've got to start to get
into meditation because meditation is
it's a [ __ ] tug-of-war and meditation
is pulling yourself back from this
[ __ ] magnet this is the man because
we make adder we make a dirty magnet in
America I love America
but we also you know we've let a lot of
greed come into this life and a lot of
hypocrisy here that are we haven't we
haven't let it it has happened and and
that is a dirty magnet that I feel like
is pulling against a lot of us a lot of
times thanks for calling man I'm trying
to stay woke
that's what they say out there what else
do we have here man we got a couple more
calls um let me see here we go homeward
hey Theo uh if you could have lunch like
just a regular afternoon lunch but it
can be with anyone in the world past
present or future and most importantly
what would you talk about and uh I guess
the have a good day man oh definitely
thank you thank you for saying have a go
begin I don't even tell you what I did
this weekend dude I realized that this
[ __ ] show I mean no it's about how
it's about this past weekend anymore
how [ __ ] know what it's about
you know it was pretty cool the other
night uh speaking of Joe Rogan yes I'm
gonna continue name-drop him he was
bringing me on stage and it was pretty
cool uh cuz he goes he's got a great
podcast this past weekend and man that
made me feel pretty good you know that
was pretty cool
just that he knew you know and you know
and that's what I realized it's like we
just it made me feel it
feel accepted you know it made me feel
like somebody had thought about me for
once or just that they knew something
about me you know we just want to feel
like we're part of that's it that's it
and I got to start making it a golden
mom and I get up in the morning to do
something each day that makes somebody
else feel a part of something you know
I'm going to start put that into some
kind of a daily reflection or something
you know or some type of a thing um
let's take this call dinner with anybody
else re lunch though I love first of all
let's do said lunch man lunch with
anybody I mean it would be my father you
know my father now would be a hundred
and eight years old if you were alive it
so would be my father outside of that
and what would I talk to my dad about
let me think and here's the thing that
my dad gonna be a hundred and eight
because if he is I'm just gonna be
[ __ ] reminding him of [ __ ] that he
doesn't know about anymore so but it
would be nice to see him you know my dad
wore that Old Spice he wore that Old
Spice Cologne or whatever it was or what
even Cologne was aftershave but man when
you grew up around aura dude I'm from if
you had [ __ ] aftershave that was
Cologne you know I'm saying [ __ ] if you
had a nice soap that could [ __ ] be
Cologne you know I remember the hottest
girl I ever met growing up when I was
real young
she I thought she had on perfume and of
his hairspray so I still catch a [ __ ]
quick rection
when I [ __ ] you know I'm saying you
[ __ ] blow a quarter of an ounce up of
Aqua Net in the daddy's [ __ ] snout
the damn boy I'll puff dick right out
the front bra my dick will start puffing
um who would I have you know it could be
Michael Landon you know I loved I loved
Michael Landon as a child I think we all
thought he was our dad you know I think
I envisioned him as this idea of a dad
you know that I wanted you know that I
romanticized about you know a dad that
taught me about hard work and that
worked at the mill and that you know and
that just that helped me through moments
so I
enough to just be inside of moments by
myself that's the hardest thing for a
child I feel like is is being in a
moment and not being able to ask for
help because then that kind of [ __ ]
still resonates as an adult you know I'm
[ __ ] 38 and I won't even ask for help
when I need it I need help we can't say
that it's so crazy we can't say that I
wonder if it's inside of us just as like
this fabric of being a man that you that
we can't say that or is that something
that we've created in society I can't I
need help and we're afraid to say it I
wonder if that's universal is that an
American thing why do you think we're
afraid to ask for help are we afraid to
ask for help I think that's probably a
neat topic for next week we might leave
this episode right here we might leave
this episode right here who would I have
lunch with you know I love Richard Pryor
I don't watch a ton of comedy but I
loved him so it'd have to be somebody
probably that's gone you know who it
would be I think I think it would be my
dad's mom because I do
love to know what my dad was like when
he was a little kid that would be pretty
cool he noted here you know our when I
was uh you know when I was young out
whenever I would go anywhere I would
write a postcard to my kids that I've
never had you know and I have a bunch at
home I get a stack of them from all
across America and some places around
the world but I would cinnamon a
postcard
you know unborn children and I'm sure
way [ __ ] creepy for the postmaster to
get but I just I would just tell him
about where I where I was I tell him if
I admit sometimes I write on there even
if I met a girl or something I met
so-and-so maybe you know I don't think
she's gonna be your mom or maybe she
could be or me you know I don't know I
would try to just you know I was here I
was this is what I did this week I was
just trying to let him know about what
I'd been up to because one thing I hated
about but having an old dad was I I
never knew about him you know I never
knew about what he was like I knew about
him just you know in the brief time I
knew him but I never got to you know
have a good conversation whoa you know
what tell me about you know tell me
about the first girl you kissed or tell
me about you know what you you know used
to you know think about when you were a
kid or just tell me about anything you
know I just wanted more so I never one
of my kids if I ever have any to have
moments where they didn't know you know
just that they didn't know where I was
or what I was doing or I wanted to try
and fill in as many blanks as I could so
it'd probably be maybe my grandmother
but a famous person [ __ ] man that is
hard isn't it you know it would probably
be uh people that have suffered you know
I'd probably sit with someone who is a
slave owner someone who was a slave
someone who
you know maybe was like a prisoner
[Music]
people like that you know just to maybe
get it really see what things were like
in that time from their perspective so
probably people maybe not suffers but
people in different time periods so you
could know she could get a feel of what
life was like then you know I don't know
that's a good question and we'll put
that out there for you guys to what who
would you have lunch with who would you
sit with and why who would be a great
person to sit with let's leave it there
let's hit the hotline
let's hit the hotline nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three and
let me know who would you have lunch
with and why someone throughout time and
for you guys we won't make it a family
member I don't think but actually it's
okay if it is yeah I don't want to put
any ramifications on it then it's
[ __ ] kind of weird to suddenly just
say but you can't have this person yeah
I can't think of who else I would like
you know I used to love Nell Carter then
Nell Carter was an actress and I loved
you know oh I loved Sidney Poitier and I
loved I loved uh who else man Heather
Locklear you know I thought Heather
Locklear was hot so those would be some
people I think I would probably yeah I
want to hear I want to spend time around
or just want to talk to maybe have lunch
with her some people who would you hit
the hotline ninety five six six four
nine five zero three and we'll come back
next week we'll have oh man we got Joey
Diaz coming in we got Jeanie buss Jocko
willing and go hit good look harass
people I'm trying to get Deon Cole in
here I've been trying to get on Marlon
Wayans I keep saying it to them and they
say they will and then they don't
respond
people say will diversify the podcast
I'm trying in okay and I need some great
Latinos out there thankfully we got Joey
cocoa Diaz that Cuban Hebrew [ __ ]
Wonder Man coming in you know and we're
gonna try to keep diversifying it and it
shows me I probably got to diversify
some of my universe a little bit you
know we had Bobby Lee we got David so we
got Joe Jitsu kawa we got some neat
people coming in and we're still
learning we're learning as we [ __ ] go
but I want to thank everybody for being
there for me this past week man it
really meant a lot dude you know some of
these calls came in somehow I can't even
play you from the voicemails and stuff
but they just hit me right in the
[ __ ] heart and I'm grateful you know
I'm grateful that I just know suddenly I
know a lot of good people that I don't
even know yet that haven't even met in
person and that's beautiful that's
really beautiful to me we're gonna
continue to do the single mom thing I
think we have one from Minneapolis
that's set up some people got upset last
week about the single mom for Oxnard my
producer Chris Perez told me that you
know a lot of people thought that it was
just her boyfriend called up and just
tried to get basically a free date for
his lady and I understand that that's
probably a little bit of Bend in the
rules I guess but we didn't exactly have
complete rules but for me you know I
think about it more as like the kids the
kids get to know that their mom is out
and that she's safe I mean so that's
where the value is would it be would it
be better for you as a single mom she
just went out with a friend or she you
know it's tough because we were asking
people to nominate a single mother but
but we'll figure out as we go you know
but if you're just trying to take the
bread you know you're just trying to
save a little bread and not have to take
your you know girl you're datin out you
know I don't know if that's for this if
this is for that you know I think maybe
this is we just want to you know you do
want to celebrate a single mom and so if
it's a friend maybe yeah maybe that's
better if it's a friend not somebody
you're dating that might be good it
could be your daughter you know you're
you're very proud of
you know but my thing is I just love to
have a moment and those kids if they're
young or if they're old or whatever you
know and maybe they would be so young
you don't even know their mom's going
she's out for the night even though they
have a babysitter but maybe one day in
their hearts we'll just have this little
extra feeling in there that there was a
day or night where their mother was out
and about and she was safe in the world
because that's there's something it does
something to a kid you know it does
something to a kid when they know that
their mom is safe when they're not
worried about their mother when they're
not because then they can be a kid you
can't be a kid and be worried you can't
do it you can't not do it I love you
guys man be good to yourselves I hope
you will let's celebrate
living on the way out of here we're just
gonna take it out with the good old
Spencer Jacob growl man he does it every
time
thank you for listening to this past
weekend subscribe go subscribe to this
ok subscribe to the podcast iTunes and
YouTube I don't care
subscribe man
[Music]
thank you to go Yaya's thank you to
lakeside maybe
[Music]
and go support that beardbrand - we got
to keep some kind of advertisement guys
[Music]
those are all good products we'll put
the links below
celebrate all y'all
all your pain I messed it up
have some fun while we all die
[Music]
and this is Spencer Jacob growl with
that hitter celebrate we'll put a link
to that as well
[Music]
well we forgot the video calls we'll get
to them next week
sorry about that lucky I remember to put
my shorts on be good to yourselves
[Music]
celebrate
No
[Music]
let's have some fun well we died
thank you guys for being there for me
man
appreciate it
[Music]
let's have some fun while we all die go
party a baby congratulations it doesn't
pour II ate a diamond baby Dustin
Diamond Poirier son we'll see you guys
next week be good to yourselves you
probably deserve